uh so
uh hello everyone welcome to the second
session of itcs the main topic of this
session will be on complexity theory
including randomization average
complexity and crypto and kindness of
approximation
and unique conjecture and also to the
render self-reduction
so each speaker has 11 minutes of talk
time and one minute of question time
and the question time also allows the
next speaker to tap
and i will try to hint to you while you
are running outside of your part time
so first we are kind of running to do
the third part on prg
okay so hi everybody can you hear me can
you see the screen
okay so my name is ryan chartier and i'm
going to talk about how this assumptions
need for extreme high-end pseudorandom
generated and faster accommodation
this is joint work with immanuel
okay so
in 97 the actual legend showed
that vbp equals p assuming certain
complexity theoretic hardness
assumptions
more specifically they showed how to
construct high-end pseudo-random
generators
and by that i mean pseudo-random
generators that stretch order of logan
random beats into m pseudo-random beats
and such pseudo-random generators are
optimal up to constant factors and are
based on assumptions that are necessary
at least up to constant factors so this
is the result of impliazo and weight
result and as we all know a
pseudo-random generator is a function
that stretches objects into
m bits and such that for every circuit d
of size m i'm using circuits of size
exactly the size of the output
the circuit d does not distinguish the
uniform distribution from the output of
the pseudonym generator and the
distinguishing advantage that i'm
looking at is a constant let's say one
over ten
so what impariation leaders did is that
they constructed these high epsilon
generators which are called high-end
they are optimal up to constant what do
i mean by that that the c length is
optimal up to a constant it's order of
log n the best you can hope for is one
times log n and they use the assumptions
which are necessary at least are two
concepts that are implied from such
pseudonym generators at least up to a
constant factors
and
it is well known that if you have a high
end pseudorandom generator then dpp
equals p or in other words there exists
a constant c so that every randomized
algorithm in time n can be simulated in
deterministic time m to the c and this
is great we all like this theory
recently motivated by fast randomization
faster randomization meaning means
trying to get the most efficient
simulation that you can get say trying
to minimize this constant c
two beautiful papers one by uh doron
moscovitz o and
and the other by chen and tel are
referred to these two papers as demos
and ct from now on construct what i'll
call extreme high-end pseudorandom
generators what are extreme high-end
pseudo-volume generators these are
generators which are not only optimal up
to constant factors but they are
optimizing their constants they're
they're optimal up to one plus linear or
one factor they stretch one plus zero or
one log n random beats into m
pseudo-random
so these are strong absolute random
generators and these two works
constructed these pseudo-randomly
generated with these extreme high-end so
i'm generate based on stronger
assumptions where the assumptions are
stronger both quantitatively
and qualitatively
now
qualitatively stronger assumptions are
in some sense necessary because we want
a a quality
sorry quantitatively stronger
assumptions are in some sense necessary
because we want quantitatively stronger
pseudonym generators we want to learn
generators we better stretch but it's
not at all clear that we need a
qualitatively stronger assumptions
any and indeed the open problem that we
want to consider is whether we can get
extreme high-end pseudorandom generators
based on the impaleazzo business on
assumption without changing it
qualitatively and only quantitatively
scaling it so that it will be
correct for extreme high-end pseudonym
generators so this is the problem that
we want to look at
and the issue why why we can't use the
old proofs they're starting from
imperial with this one and later work is
that we can't use harder simplification
in the hybrid argument it costs too much
if you want to construct extreme high
amps to the one in general
now i'm interested in proving
limitations improving lower bounds on
proof techniques and this is good and
for that reason the way i want to state
this problem is in the following way the
question that i want to ask is is there
a black box proof for the open program
because what i'll try to show is that
there's no blackboard
and i'll call a blackbox proof from
a quantitatively properly scaled
imperial vegas or assumption to extreme
high-end
generator and extreme black box so what
we but what what we are interested in in
this paper is does there exist an
extreme black box proof
and the answer is that we don't know but
we can rule out certain approaches
so what are our results
our first result is that
in every black box proof even a black
box proof that is not extreme the
construction that takes a very hard
function f and marks it into a pseudo
random generator g must have certain
specific properties
more precisely it is well known that
every black box surrounding generator is
also an extractor this is a celebrated
result of february 79
and what we show is that every black box
pseudorandom generator when you view it
as an extractor has a certain property
that we interpret as a weakness so what
is this property the property is that
when you think of a black box pseudonym
generator as an extractor there is a
large entropy source in which quite a
few outputs of this extractor are they
are fixed
now this doesn't contradict the fact
that this is an assumption but typical
extractors do not have this property and
by that i mean but if you were to choose
a function at random believe high
probability it will be an extractor it's
a standard calculation
nevertheless what we show is that if you
take a random function it is unlikely to
have this property of this weakness as
an extractor and the way we interpret
this is that there is a difference
between black box to the random
generators and extractors and this may
explain why it is hard to come up with
new black box proofs of random
generators moreover now that we know how
such black box proof should look like
how the construction should look like
maybe it will now be easier to find new
constructions because we know that the
ones that we do have
although they work in the high end they
fail in the extreme high
and this
approach is also used to prove the next
result i'm going to tell you about
so the next result i'm going to tell you
about is
that the approach of demos
cannot yield an extreme black box proof
so what do i mean by that dmoz used an
approach which i'll call a pseudoentropy
generator plus extractor which was
already suggested in the past
more specifically
episode
peg a pseudo-entropy generator is a weak
form of a pseudonym generator which
doesn't guarantee that the output
distribution is pseudorandom instead it
only guarantees that the output
distribution has large computational
entropy so it's a weaker form of the
pseudo-running generator and if you want
to construct a pseudo-random generator
the peg plus extractor approach is to
first use your hardness assumption the
heart function to construct the
pseudoentropy generator and then in
order to construct the final
pseudorandom generator g apply an
extractor of the output of a
pseudo-entropy generator to extract this
computational
entropy and this is the approach used by
demos
now if you want this constructed
pseudorandom generator g to be extreme
if you want it to have very short seed
then since we're already paying for the
seedling for the extractor then the
seedling for the pseudoentropy generator
must be extremely short it should be
shorter than the best possible seeds
generators
and and this is indeed what demos
achieve
and our result is that if you try to
look at black box proofs that construct
pgs
from the quantitatively properly scaled
in paragraphs on assumptions if you want
to imitate the approach of demos
from the assumptions that we we are used
to assuming
then such black box proofs cannot have
very short scp for pgs the png that you
will construct cannot have a very short
seat and therefore it is impossible to
have an extreme black box proof using
the peg plus extractor approach
and
this same
proof also implies a limitation on
pseudonym generators for quantify their
randomization because they are closely
related to pseudo-entropy generator and
this explains in retrospect why the
paper of demos uses additional
assumptions just to say i mentioned that
demos uses a qualitatively stronger
assumption than the one used by
imperative on which the heart function
is also hard not only for deterministic
circuits but also for a version of
non-deterministic cells right so now we
have an excuse why we were not supposed
to use that approach to get to get such
a result assuming the assumption that we
like to assume bring palettes on
assumption
our third result concerns the paper of
shen and del
city
and it shows that the approach of
challenge 10 can't yield an extreme
black box proof but here the limitations
that we show only holds if you use
hardest amplification and the hybrid
argument so let me celebrate this result
so what is the approach used by uh
challenger channel using approach which
i'll call the prg composition approach
more specifically they construct
pseudorandom generator g by composing
two pseudo-random generator
where the first generator g1
is a generator that is constructed from
the
assumptions that we're used to assuming
from the quantitatively properly scale
the periods of biggest assumption and it
uses the tools that we are used to using
the hardest amplification and the hybrid
argument and one way to think about this
first generator is that we this is
basically pushing what we know about the
highest amplification in hybrid argument
to the limit so g1 is the best we we
know how to do we've had a
simplification in the hybrid argument
and then we compose this generator g1
with a separate generator g2
g2 is a generator with mild stretch it
has polynomial stretch and not
exponential stretch but it needs to have
additional properties for example it
needs to be it needs to be running
almost linear time in the output length
in order for this both for this
composition to be correct
and we don't know how to construct
pseudo such pseudorandom generators from
the imperial venus on type
assumption and because of that a ct
assume the existence of one-way
functions or cryptography to obtain
cryptographic pseudorandom generators
which have this property they have
polynomial stretch and they can run in
almost linear time in the output
an actual question that you can ask when
you look at this prg composition is can
we that that plural generator g1 is
already constructed from the assumption
but we like assuming
right so can we use the quantitatively
properly scaled in palliative videos on
assumption with the black box proof to
construct a pseudo-random generator g2
if we could do that and we could get rid
of the additional
okay
and our result is that it's impossible
for black box proofs that use hardness
amplification and the hybrid argument
and this explains in retrospect why
can't intel need to use additional
assumptions but unlike the previous
result it doesn't rule out that maybe
the prg composition approach can be
carried out without harder
simplification in the hybrid argument
via some a different argument that we
haven't discovered yet
and the result that we actually show
here is what is called lower bounds on
hardness amplification or if you're
recording theories this is a lower bound
on the number of queries of locally this
decodable codes with huge lists and it
is related to past works in this area
but it uses very different techniques
because somehow this
setting will be extremely high and
it's very much more challenging
sorry okay
so let me conclude uh uh
so this is a summary of the talk let me
also comment that there are additional
ways in which one can hope to construct
in what we
would hope to can hope to prove dpp
would speak or do fast randomization
based on hard functions and we don't
rule out these additional approaches for
specifically a new paper by a challenge
from last year and let me just mention
two open problems
one uh
do we really need to pay the cost of a
hardest amplification in the hybrid
argument in black box group for
constructing pseudorandom generators i'm
not sure what the right answer is
whether we should or shouldn't but if we
shouldn't and we're hoping to prove a
limitation on on blackbox proofs then as
you can see we need to develop
techniques to prove even weak bounds on
general box proof subscriber and
generators because as you can see our
results only handle black box proof with
specific approaches like a pg plus
extractor or prg composition right so
this is so
these are open programs so thank you and
that's it
yeah thanks so much rona for the very
interesting talk we probably don't have
time for a question now so if you have
questions just ask in the chat and
work on the next bigger
raffle
giving the talk on error-less versus
error-prone average phase complexity
yeah sorry just trying to do that
okay in the meantime guys i want to ask
that your prg results apply to seeking
cell generator as well
just
how about kicking that generator because
that
random question comes to my mind
it doesn't i don't think it
rules out heating set generators but it
does it doesn't rule out pseudo-random
generators with error that approaches
one
right
now
yeah thanks thanks legit um so i'm going
to be speaking about errorless versus
error-prone average case complexity
um
and uh this is joint work with srishi
hirahara
um
okay so um the focus of this talk is on
two notions of average case complexity
um so when we talk about average case
complexity we're starting distributional
problems so we have a computational
problem on a language perhaps a research
problem together with the distribution
um and we want to solve the problem um
with uh high probability over the
distribution of instances so uh in this
case let's just focus on addition forms
languages and consider some sequence of
distributions or inputs of size n
the question is given an input sample
from this distribution
um
say d sub n or instance of length n can
you efficiently decide whether x is an l
or not with high probability so either
randomness is just over the instances
or in other words additional problem l
easy on average with respect to d
and uh there's two natural ways at least
in which you can uh you can model this
problem um and this corresponds to um
whether you're allowed to make errors or
not um when um yeah so for most
instances you'll be given the correct
answer and when you're not giving the
correct answer um do you know that
you're not getting the correct answer
and therefore will be able to say that
you don't know um
because uh so either the correct answer
you don't know or i may sometimes make a
mistake and these notions have both been
considered extensively in literature so
the first notion is errorless where you
don't make a mistake and the second is
error prone
um so uh the first notion of errorless
is often called average p um when you're
talking about uh decision uh by
polynomial time algorithms and the error
prone version uh is often referred to as
heuristic p
um
so we
sort of study the um
the relationship between these two
notions and this is a very natural
question and um as i'll say later it was
raised already with bhagavad-gita in a
well-known survey on average case
complexity but it doesn't seem to have
received um much attention um so uh as
far as we know the first system actually
started relating these notions um in in
some cases analogous to zpp versus bpp
which is a form of more well-known
problem um how does zero error probably
stick down related to boundary
probability time in this case uh that
we're considering here the errors over
the space of instances rather than over
the randomness of an algorithm
so just as a motivation um uh let's
consider this uh there's a survey of
impossible that i just mentioned and he
describes five possible worlds of uh
complexity cryptography um ranging from
algorithmic
um world where p equals np to
cryptomania where there's public key
cryptography and um there's all these
words in between heuristic of a b
naughty np and np's easy on average
basically when p is harder on average
but they're like one way functions don't
exist and many crypt where one-way
functions exist but public key
cryptography doesn't
and for these two worlds pestilent and
heuristica um one can ask well um what
exactly do you mean here by on average
by easy on average or hard on average is
it an errorless sense or the error prone
sense
and this is uh an important question i
mean especially um the context of some
recent work um
so uh hirahara building on work by um by
karma simone parser cameron koloklov
showed that
some very natural problems related to
common growth complexity the circuit
size problem and the problem of
minimizing time monochromal complexity
have worse case to average case
reductions but then the average case
hardness is zero error hardness so the
errorless heuristics hardness in the
aerologistic sense
and there's also exciting recent work by
liu and pass showing how to base uh
one-way functions on the average case
hardness of min kt the problem with
minimizing time boundary more complexity
but there the hardness is on the is in
the error-prone sense so the question of
connecting error-less hardness and
error-prone hardness is very relevant to
whether in base one-way functions of
worst-case hardness of problems like uh
minimum time boundary or complexity or
not so that's one motivation the context
of recent work and another one um
is about um
there's another notion of complexity
scalability complexity where um it's
been shown in recent work by uh
by random myself that
in the
when you're talking about um the
hardness and the errorless setting um
for that notion that's equivalent to x
not equal to bpp but hardness in the
error prone setting is equal to the
existence of one-way functions so of
course it's of interest to relate error
prone to this error-less hardness
because if you could do that then you
could base cryptography in exponential
ppp which would be at the very least a
surprising result
um okay so uh yeah so we're interested
in kind of like looking more carefully
at what these average case notions are
and how they relate to each other
and in fact it also asks this question
in his original survey so if this dnp is
in heuristic p if you can solve
distribution problems in np
um in the error prone sense can you also
solve on the arrow less sense
um
and yeah here's the definition of the
error prone sense there is an algorithm
such that it gives the right answer the
probability of at least one minus one
okay over the uh distribution and the
errorless sense um you require that for
any um instance you either give the
correct answer or don't know and
um
you require the original condition um
as in the case of heuristic p that the
um the answer l of x will probably at
least one minus one over k
okay so um what do we uh uh so and this
uh errorless notion is equivalent to
levin's notion of expected for long time
um
so what do we show well so the main sort
of conceptual contribution is a
connection with uh the well-known notion
of instance checkers um
so an instance checker sort of an oracle
procedure for a language where um if
you're given the languages oracle you
always give the right answer and if
you're given some other oracle you give
either the right answer or you say don't
know the high probability so that's um
sort of and notion has been very well
studied since the early 90s was defined
by bloom and cannon and uh it's closely
related to theory of attractive proofs
and pcp's
so
what we show is that these two notions
of kind of on the one hand instance
checking and the other hand of relating
errorless and error complexity are very
closely related so if you have an
instance checking for an empty complete
problem which is a long-standing open
question complexity theory to show that
np complete problems are instant
checkable then um
error-prone heuristics do imply
aerialist heuristics for uh for for np
um and for example of ph and mets in a
tractor-proof system with a ph honest
prover then um that implies a kind of
certain convention checkability which
implies a connection for distributional
ph
so let me um the current best result is
just that you have interactive proofs
with uh honest brewers in
the
encountering fee
so let me just describe the results more
clearly so first result is an
equivalence between reductions from
error to error prone um uh average case
complexity and a certain notion of
instance checker a slightly relaxed
notion a non-adaptive average v3 slash
poly instance checker and so these two
notions of of kind of reducing airless
direct prone and having instance checker
of this sort are actually equivalent we
get an exact equivalence in the previous
slide i suggested one direction of this
going from instance checkability to a
reduction but you can show the other
direction too if you relax a notion of
instance checkability
um and so this provides a new approach
for errorless styrofoam production
and relates our problem to a well-known
open problem about instance checking np
and we can in fact unconditionally
construct um a somewhat weaker neutral
instance checkability instead of average
vp if you asked about heuristic vp slash
polyester checkers you can construct
them unconditionally
um a second result is unconditional so
we give some unconditional results for
the equivalence between irrelevance and
error pronounced case complexities for p
and u p insect core up
so for example if distribution of
problems on p are in nc one in heuristic
at which case a sense then they're also
in nc one in
an errorless average case sense and note
that um the problem of finding like a
worst case average case reduction for p
is a long-standing open problem so what
we show is that if you want to relate
errors to error prone rather than worst
case to average case that is something
you can do unconditionally
um and this goes through instance
checking for p complete problems and
similarly uh we have a connection for up
intersect core up unconditionally
now final result is about hitting such
generators such as prgs um so in the
complexity theoretically realization
settings know that heating set
generators are equivalent to prg's when
the cryptographic setting with adversary
can be more powerful than the generator
this is unknown and um we use our
results to show some new equivalences
between the two notions for generators
that are seed extending where the first
part of the output is just a c
so
such generators cannot be secured
cryptographic setting but they are
interesting in the setting where um
where uh
adversaries are uh weaker than the
generator and we show a sort of an
equivalence here that a seed extending
heading side generator with non-trivial
seed length um
implies a heating saturated with small
seedlings enter the epsilon seed length
and this is equivalent to prgs
and
like um even the first two items
stretching the seed of an hsg
we don't have any other way of doing
this rather than using our connection
between arrowless and error prone so the
way we show this theorem is that
if if one holds then we use this to to
show
errorless hardness
and then we show that since errorless
harness and plus output hardness we can
use airflow partners to build a prg and
that implies two so it goes through the
connection to adolescent air from
hardness and we have no way uh that we
know off of doing it directly
um so that's a little bit of
a proof sketch i don't know if there's
time for that how much time do i have
okay one minute okay let me just um go
straight to the um
[Music]
conclusion then so yeah so we sort of
initiated the study of relating rls and
error flow and complexity we have this
kind of um connection between instance
checking there's long story open
question of whether np compute calls for
instance checkers and whether you can
relate analysis orders to error prone
partners um and then we have some
uncontrollable results for p and up
inside core up and a couple of open
questions remain
um first of all whether you can control
an instance checker or even even this
weaker node from instance checkoff and
complete problems which would imply that
you could relate and electron hormones
for np
or it can be present evidence against
this so a famous work of both mountain
travel sun shows there's no non-adaptive
worst case established case reduction
unless prolonged hierarchy collapses
um an airless electron reduction is a
weaker notion and
the question is whether we can extend
the techniques of obnoxious revision to
also rule this out under some natural
complexity assumption thanks
so much for
giving a talk uh
yeah so we should we have some time for
like one or two questions anyone have
questions
hi rahul i have a good question in this
equivalence i in this equivalence
between
and hitting set generators do you can
you also prove it in the almost
everywhere case or is just infinitely
often thank you
um uh that's a good question i i think
it does work
in both settings um yeah i've i've got
to kind of think about it a bit more but
my intuition is that it does work in
both sides because i think the um the
equivalence between errorless and error
prone for b i think it doesn't depend on
whether uh you have io almost everywhere
that would be my suspicion
i see thank you
thank you yeah i guess we have to move
to the next speaker sure stop sharing
yeah thanks
um
the next task will be given by stannah
and reduction for
knowledge games to korean universe so
welcome
okay thank you reggie um
so
yeah i'll speak about this uh work with
ronan and dan
uh
longer versions of this of this uh talk
are available online
uh so
you know the the point of this session
as far as i'm concerned is to answer
questions so if anyone has any questions
while i speak just just raise your hand
and ask
um
okay so
right so this is
you see
here
um so this talk is about
um
you know it's towards the
proving uni games conjecture if we ever
to prove the only game's conjecture we
should be able to show a reduction from
a problem that we know is empty hard
to the uniqueness conjecture to the uni
games problem
um in
2006
in 16 sorry in stock 16 bashcode and i
had a paper
that said
let's just try to aim for the boolean
version of the unique games conjecture
this is basically hardness of max cut
and this is very much the heart of the
uni games conjecture
um
and
here's a problem that we proved was was
np hard
and
and and here is a candidate reduction
that we have from this problem to
boolean unique games
um so so we had we put forward this this
reduction we actually had that reduction
for a long time before that
um
[Music]
and but but we didn't have a proof uh
for for this reduction
in
and in fact uh the there were some
issues there and so so the main idea of
the of that reduction
it was instead of using the long code in
in hardness of approximation reductions
instead encode
information with half spaces
um
which
no one did before that
but but we had good uh reasons to to uh
suggest that this this would be good uh
uh towards a hardness of boolean unique
games
uh for technical reason we used um
not quite tough spaces but but what we
call periodic half spaces
and some experts were kind of worried
about this choice um
and indeed we didn't we didn't have a
proof
and this new work let me just say right
there is also the question assuming that
you prove the brilliant version of the
unique games conjecture can you prove
that the full unique games conjecture
this is a great question
uh but but
this is known as strong prayer
repetition we're not going to talk about
this
um this is not the the focus of this
talk
anyway
so so we wanted to go and and and
analyze the the stock 16 reduction
in
and and what we were able to do
is is
basically analyze it
uh but instead of starting with a
problem that we know is uh and behind we
start with a very similar problem that
we don't know how to prove that and be
hard it is in the same spirit also for
it semi-definitely programming
algorithms won't do the trick
um
but
but from that we're able to prove the
the
do the reduction let me say that we also
figure out how to we we actually put
forward
er what at least i feel is the is the
right way to do the reduction from the
known and behalfness
results to boolean uni games so we get
rid of these periodic half spaces it's
just based on on half spaces
um it's also a
you know an np reduction the original
reduction was a
an exponential size reduction it was
only meant to to um
rule out uh
polynomial time algorithms for boolean
unit gains
so so we actually get a reduction we we
have a candidate reduction that that is
an np hardness reduction
um right to polynomial size reduction
uses only half spaces
um but
we still don't know how to prove that
but we are able to prove
um
assuming this slightly different
you know a problem
okay so this is what's going on in this
work and
if anyone has any questions this would
be a good time
to ask this is the big picture slide
and if not i'll just i'll just continue
okay
uh
okay good and so
i need to tell you a few things i need
to tell you what's this boolean unique
games conjecture um i need to tell you
in what is this so so what is this uh
what's what's the known empty hardness
result what's the wishful empty harness
result
in
and i need to tell you what what's going
on in in this work
perhaps let me do it in an
unusual
setup and
let me just skip to the end
and tell you something about what comes
into the proof
um so so in order to analyze uh this
reduction right this is this was
extremely challenging
um
and
we went and proved a new concentration
theorem or new law degree testing
theorem
um
that
i think is a
completely independent interest so let
me tell you about that a little
um
so suppose that you have some some
function so we're talking about real
functions
you know on the two norm
and you have some constant degree
and then you take this
you take the space
and then you can see the random
random hyperplane
in this space so this is of dimension
one minus the the total dimension of the
space you could look at the function
restricted to the hyperplane
and you can ask what's the what's the
the great d part right so so right just
like there is for analysis of the over
the boolean hypercube
um
you can also have uh
over real function so so uh there is a
meat uh expansion there is a gigan power
expansion getting power is over the
sphere uh hermities over the gaussian
space in
right and in this notion of the greedy
part right what's the law degree of the
function is is well defined so you can
look at this restricted function you can
look at what's this low degree part of
this restricted function
and what we prove is that this local
low degree part of the function is
actually very close
to the global
uh low degree part of the function so
this is the global low degree part now
here restricted to the hyperplane
those two
are extremely similar uh they're similar
up to one over the dimension
of the function
um right so this is uh exactly what we
call a low degree testing theorems there
is uh you know what the law degree part
locally versus what's the law degree
about globally and the tool uh similar
um
you can use sort of free analysis
techniques and and prove some result of
this sort but this would only give you
one other squad k
which is which is not
uh would be useless completely for for
our needs for this unique games
conjecture um
and and the truth is that the the the
right deviation is is one over k one
over the dimension and the tight example
is is a half space
um
and and we actually prove that this is
the right deviation with high
probability for for all functions
um
and it's actually it's a very
interesting technique
um
so the the technique is
use
schwermann
presentation theory
and you say that um
that
the function
um
right the the the the second moment of
of this actually only depends on the
spectrum of the function and not on the
function itself
and this uh
reduces the problem to a problem in
two-dimensional space still it's a very
difficult problem in two-dimensional
space and this is you know why we need
to uh
prove stuff
um
but but it is uh
an easier setting to work with uh this
technique was used once before for a
sampling theorem right you have a
function and you ask what's the average
globally and what's the average on a
hyper plane so this was done in a paper
of
dead regive and boss cloud
it's
extremely non-trivial that you can take
a technique that works um um
for sampling just for averages right
this is the degree zero part of the
function and actually lift it to general
a low degree part of the function to
load degree testing um and and this is
what we were able to do with quite a lot
of effort
um
yeah so so this is the main technical uh
theorem that that
goes into
the analysis the new analysis of the
reduction
in
although i think that i probably
use much of my time um
are there any questions
dimensional sphere
we call such things law degree testing
theory
okay
[Music]
and they're known with the same uh
this one over k thing is the same
usually
yeah the when we talk about logarithmic
testing theorems often we consider much
lower dimensional
local parts um
here we we only needed
quite high dimensional
and
yeah but but this spirit of theorems
is very well known in you know over the
sk discrete domains
um
but but we are able to prove it
over uh gaussian space
in
right with with tight parameters which
which was right this was well the
challenge was
i see a vague question although
different notions of reductions it could
be of
interest in this setting you mean for
uni games
yeah no
of course many many versions of
reductions could be interesting
in
right you don't have to prove and be
hardness you could prove you could prove
uh other um other results except that we
don't know how to do those things
um
yeah but i mean we do have a candidate
uh
candidate uh reduction that would prove
and be hardness and and i i believe it
i i stand behind it i believe it with
all my heart
um
i think we have to move on to the next
talk uh thanks so much dana for the
exciting talk about the game transaction
and uh the next talk will be given by
uh
gail
and the
are you two giving the talk together
yes
okay it's good so
with that other person
sorry
oh yeah
just maybe you can share the screen and
uh
react okay so why can't riyadh and the
girl vote for the super random staff
reduction for empty complete problems
yeah
thank you thank you luigi um so my name
is gollum here with riyadh and today
we'll talk about pseudorandom
self-reductions for np-complete problems
our starting point is random
self-production we say that the language
l is randomly self-reducible if designed
in membership in l can be reduced in
polynomial time to designed in
membership in l for uniformly random
instances as we can see here in this
slide so we have our worst case instance
x
and we can reduce
the design membership in l in polynomial
time to design membership
of these random queries um to l
there are
famous examples and include the discrete
logarithm and the permanent of a matrix
um now these two problems are assumed
not to be np-complete and so it is
natural to ask if we can find
um an np-complete language with a random
self-reduction
and the answer is a conditional note
finding bound fourth row for prove that
unless the polynomial hierarchy
collapses to the third level
there is no non-adaptive random
self-reduction for np-complete problems
here non-adaptive means that future
queries cannot depend on previous
queries of the reduction
and the proof idea is that if we have a
language l
in np and it admits a non-adaptive
random self-reduction
then we can construct
an am poly protocol for the complement
of l
these results were later improved by
mcdonough venturevisan
[Music]
yes
so
one relaxation suggested by
hirihara and santhanam is to consider
pseudorandom self-reduction
um and sodaran himself reduction
basically says that instead of requiring
the queries of the reduction to be
random we require them to be
pseudorandom with respect to some
complexity class and here we use um
the definition
of pseudonym so we say that the sequence
of distribution is uh pseudorandom with
respect to c if we cannot if every
member in the classic cannot distinguish
between
um a sample drawn from this distribution
and a uniform sample with a
distinguishing advantage more than
epsilon n and here in this talk we will
consider epsilon n to be a function that
goes to zero so it's going to be a
little of one and not a constant
so the notion of pseudorandom
self-reduction is very similar and
here's the analogous slide we have our
worst case in instance x and we want to
reduce the membership uh descending
membership in l in polynomial time of
course um to decide in membership in l
for pseudorandom shares so here the
queries to the reductions are
pseudorandom
um okay so first let's see an example
for a problem also given by yarin
santanam that admits the pseudorandom
self-reduction and we don't know for
real random reduction for it i mean this
problem is the minimum circuit size
problem the mcsp uh the input is a truth
table of some function
and the output is the size of the
smallest boolean circuits that computes
this truth table
sorry
okay so here we are in sentiment show
the soda random self reduction for the
mcsp
um and we have good reasons to believe
that mcsp is not ntp complete um and
they asked if it is possible to have a
soder and themself reduction for np
complete
and they suggested that maybe um
the existence of the pseudorandom
self-reduction for mcsp further
distinguishes
mcsp for np completeness
and the reduction the way that it works
is we take the instance for the mcsp
which is just a truth table as we can
see here and we xor it with the output
of exponentially secure soda random
generator
now the output is pseudorandom almost by
definition
and they proved that this operation does
not change the answer to the mcsp by
much
that means that the output of this
xor is going to have roughly the same
circuit size as
x
and essentially we characterize very
high level reasons for this reduction
for why this redirection worked um
and we found that
this reduction worked because there
exists some pseudo-random distribution d
with small values
for the mcsp problem
whereas random inputs have large value
and xor in with this distribution
roughly keeps the value of x
and now the question is whether we can
find some np complete problem that will
also
um
satisfy these properties
and this is what we did in this work so
the first thing that we show is that the
max max click problem admits a
non-adaptive pseudo-random
self-reduction and the hardness
assumption that we use is the
non-uniform planted
click actually the same
proof the same proof that we had
actually proves a slightly stronger
theorem it proves that for every
non-trivial hereditary property pi
the problem of finding
given an input graph g the largest sub
graph in pi it also emits a
pseudo-random self-reduction um again
assuming that a non-uniform planted
clique
so um what is
the non-uniform plant clip assumption so
we have two distribution the first one
is the uniform distribution of a graph
with n vertices and the second one is a
distribution where we planted a clique
of size n to the power of epsilon in
this random graph and the conjecture is
that this distribution
is pseudorandom
with respect to polynomial size circuits
um and more formally we assume that
there exists some epsilon between zero
and a half and some tau between 0 and 1
such that
any sequence of polynomial size circuits
we have this condition which basically
means that they cannot distinguish
between the uniform distribution and the
plantar distribution with an advantage
larger than um one over n to the power
of tau
um yes so
basically now riad will explain about
the reduction the connections to the
mcsp hi yeah so i will be showing the
reduction it's actually not very complex
given a graph during with n vertices
that actually does the following first
it chooses a random subset
s of size n to the power of epsilon
it fixes the edges in s
and everything else is
then randomized so an edge inside this
will stay if it existed before
edges
outside of this or
with one side of that face will will be
random after after applying it
so what properties does this reduction
have
first
if g has a click of size k then f of g
has a click of size
k divided by n to the power 1 minus
epsilon average
because
the size of the intersection of k and
the of the click and s is k and the
power epsilon divided by
m so hyperbolic it will be at least k
half of that which is k divided by 2
times into power 5 minus epsilon which
means that the critical size doesn't
decrease by much
and the second property is that the
click size of f of g is not larger than
the clear size of g plus 3 log n with
high probability
and that's because the click size of f
of g is bounded by the fixed size of on
s and fixes on the complement of this
the click size on s is at most the click
size of g and on the compliment it is
two login on average and the
less than three again with high
probability so total it is the original
click size plus three rogaine
the third property is to the randomness
is that the distribution of g is
indistinguishable from the random
uniform distribution
uh
why is that true
and now assumes that some anniversary
can distinguish between f of g and the
random
graph r
then
the graph consider the graph f of g x r
g
this graph of course has an independent
set on s and everything else is random
uh so the graph of objects objects or k
with play with where k is the complete
graph has a click
in s with size n to the power epsilon
and everything else is random so this is
exactly the planted clique
distribution
for the graph our arcs or jigsaw players
of course is of course restrained
so we get that this adversary could
distinguish between a
a graph with a planetary of size
interval of epsilon and the uniformly
distribu
and the uniform graph
which exactly contradicts
our conjecture
actually a very similar trick was used
in the mcsp case to prove to the
randomness
uh
so we have three properties uh that the
click size doesn't decrease by much
by more than all the
by a factor of more than o into the
power one was epsilon
uh
so what we have here is absolute random
self reduction that approximates click
up to a factor of o n to the power minus
one minus epsilon
which is known to be np hard so
uh there's a reduction from this from
click to the approximation of click and
then reduction from approximation
one minute in one minute
so we can compose this reduction and get
absolute random production from crypto
itself
so
why does this reduction work first
a click is smaller random inputs it's
very hard to approximate and has some
property of
localness or stability
that is
fixing just a small subset
of the input is enough to keep the
output roughly the same
where after the similar case is n to the
power of 1 minus epsilon
and turns out that every inhibitor
property
problem has these same properties
so they are
[Music]
still very local of course and they're
hard to approximate up to one end to
performance epsilon
they're also
small enough random inputs for for our
reduction to work
so
thank you
we are running this actually so maybe we
don't have time for questions if you
have any questions you can ask them also
in the chat sorry for that
thanks so much for the talk so
the next talk will be done by russell as
well i think
thank
you yeah thanks let me just share my
clothes
okay thanks lisa so um this uh talk is
on um
paper called excluding ph specimen again
joint work with shuichi um
okay so here are the um the context
motivation are all to do with those five
um of average case complexity
um
where uh
yeah
it's it's it's sort of trying to
understand where we are in our quest to
understand average case competition
cryptography and and what the central
questions are um
and
so these five worlds where the um the
the one uh that would be sort of the
most surprising one in some ways is
algorithmic where p is equal to np
um and then um there are all these other
words where p not equal to np and where
differing degrees of average case
hardness and cryptography are possible
and it seems very very difficult to
separate algorithmically from these
other words i mean to know whether the
algorithmica is true or not is np uses p
problem which will lead to a very very
hard problem
so um it seems
that it's quite hopeless as of now
um
but
we can hope to say something about these
these other intermediate worlds so what
are these other intermediate worlds
so this this other extreme world is
cryptomania that exists public key
cryptography
um and this again is a world that's very
very hard to to rule out or to show it
holds um
but then there's intermediate worlds
where um
so in heuristica you have worst case
hardness of np but
average case easiness np is hard in the
worst case but it's easy in the average
case
there's pesciland which um is given that
name because it's somehow the worst of
all possible words that you have average
case partners so you can't solve
problems you'd like to solve um on
average at the same time you don't have
cryptography so
you can't use um sort of average case
hardness um to solve cryptographic tasks
so
one of the nice things about complexity
theory is sort of a win-win situation
where either a problem is easy or if
it's hard maybe it can be used for
pseudorandomness and photography and
pestilence is a world where yeah that
doesn't happen to the extent you'd like
um then there's minicrypt where secret
key cryptography one way functions exist
but public key cryptography doesn't
so um despite the fact that these two
words algorithm and cryptomania are very
hard to rule out we have some hope maybe
of reducing the possibilities and at
least ruling out this intermediate
worlds and um yeah that's uh that's
something that we can aspire to do
um
so
we're especially interested in ruling
out pestilent and heuristica
because that seems more within reach
and though we don't seem to have the
techniques yet to do that what we do in
this paper is uh to consider um sort of
like
an analogous worlds uh where these
problems become somewhat easier and try
to make progress
on these questions on the on these
questions in that analytics world
um so yeah the ultimate goal is to
decide which of these words is a true
one we
many of us probably believe that
cryptomania is the world we live in but
even ruling out algorithmic seems very
hard and we made very little progress
and we instead look at um kind of um uh
kind of a relaxed version of this where
we consider the ph versions of these
these five possible worlds
so um uh instead of considering np
versus p we consider the polynomial
hierarchy versus p so ph algorithmic is
just the world where ph equals p of
course that's the same as np equals p
because
uh
we know that uh
ph contains np and np equals p implies
the whole of hormone hacking collapses
ph heuristic is a world where ph is hard
in the worst case but it's easy on
average
to define ph pesticide is not that
obvious because um it's not quite clear
where the ph analog of a one-way
function would be but at least the ph
analog of a crm generator makes um some
intuitive sense so we consider that
instead ph pestilence is a world where
ph is our average and they don't exist
ph computers around generators
um and the other two worlds uh are about
ph computer public key crypto which
again is it's not quite clear what that
should mean so we don't consider it here
we're more interested in uh ph vessel
and ph jurisdictor an earlier work of
sri chi's uh through some very
interesting results about ph eulistica
and in this paper our focus is on ph
special and um
[Music]
so um i should note here that unlike
with the original five words of empire
so there is very little relevance to
photography here because being able to
compute um a generator or in the polymer
hierarchy doesn't make it at all
practical in any way so it's not really
kind of helping us from the crypto point
of view it's more that maybe helps us
understand where the difficulties of
these problems
lie and uh help us to make partial
progress so it's very much about kind of
developing techniques to make partial
progress in these problems
um so what we do is we rule out ph
pestlin and kind of various settings so
um uh unconditionally ends as an
unconditional result
um it turns out to be quite easy to do
that in the non-uniform setting it
follows mostly from other work but the
uniform setting it takes it takes more
work and there's some interesting open
questions that remain
so um we basically show that yeah ph is
on average equal to the exist ph
computer prgs um
in the knowing form setting in the
uniform setting with small stretch
um so this world where you have hardness
on average the existence of prgs and
prg's don't exist it's just false it
it just doesn't hold
but the question of the ph heuristic uh
exists is still open and it's sort of an
interesting open question
so um the previous work on psja rustica
was by uh by shuichi where um he showed
an interesting connection between um
average case hardness of problems in ph
the distribution of ph being hard on
average
and um
the worst case hardness of a problem
related to commonwealth complexity
so um the problem of minimizing
transformer complexity um with a ph
oracle so uh there's an interesting
equivalence between a worst case
hardness result and an average case
harmonics result for ph
um
and it turns out that this is also
equivalent to um some kind of myoc
randomness phenomenon you get a ph
computer hitting set generator or some
sort of complexity separation of people
not called cpp
and morally what this implies is that ph
heuristica is excluded if you can show
somehow that this problem gap in kt to
the ph is np hard that uh every np bomb
reduces to it and that's um
that's something that we that we don't
know yet if we knew that then um we'd be
able to rule out ph heuristical so the
previous work of shuichi reduces the
question of ruling out philosophical to
showing entry hardness of
this problem
uh and um
just to kind of refer my previous talk
then the notion of average case hard
material is always uh errorless as well
as average case hardness
and what we do is it means to consider
error pronouns which case so when we
consider best length we consider uh
error-prone average case hardness um and
we uh look at the assumption that sph is
not heuristic ppp and we unconditionally
rule this out so um we present
equivalence between ph computer serum
generators absolute sounds of ph and
average case hardness of this meta
complexity problem this problem about
time bounded uh control complexity of
the ph oracle
and um yeah perhaps the most interesting
aspect of our work is that this um this
problem showing that this problem is
this phenomenal hierarchy complete even
in an error-prone sense so even when you
consider every error pronoun which case
hardness this problem is just ph
complete
um so there's two sets of results one
annoying phone case one the uniform case
and the normal form case um if you have
average case hardness of ph or uniform
distribution then um
you get average case hardness of this
problem in kt to the ph also the uniform
distribution that gives a natural
example of
a problem or distribution of problems
that's average case hard in their prone
setting for ph
and this implies the existence of ph
computer prg's non-trivial seedling or
with seed length that's enter the
epsilon or a stretched polynomial
um
and uh
yeah so this kind of is all about error
prone complexity well the previous work
is about uh errorless case
and i should mention that these
directions one implies three and four
are kind of fairly straightforward by
applying the nissan business generator
and this for this theorem the more
interesting directions are uh four and
three employees one and uh
uh yeah and one implies two
um and we also uh get equivalence with
some other uh kind of condition where
you have actually polynomial stretch
um
so this is a uniform case so the
pressure knowing from case the uniform
case we get very similar results except
that um the stretch of the prg we can
get from average case hardness is uh
sort of uh smaller it's order login
and
we're not we don't know how to get
polynomial stretch in this case
and we can get polynomial stretch um at
the expense of having sort of a
disjunction either we get performance
fresh or we get um like a tally language
it's in ph but not in bpp so that's sort
of like a
qualifier or a rider to this result i
really would like to eliminate this and
just get a polymer stretch
unconditionally
so um
so the yeah the main shortcoming result
is that we order logan stretch what we
really want is a prg with polynomial
stretch
but for this result um the heart
direction is actually getting a prg with
order log n stretch and the other
direction
um
is uh it's not trivial but it can be
done
using a previous work where you're using
a prg to get out which case
so in general what we're doing is kind
of establishing the equivalence of
average case hardness and c randomness
for ph uh against
uh both uniform and omniform adversaries
um and
the main open problem here is whether
you could by the existence of a
polynomial stretched ph computed prg is
equal to average case of p of of ph
whether you can remove this condition
here
so in conclusion i mean our results
might hint an approach was excluding
standard questions well yeah so in some
sort of like mirror world which is much
simpler than our uh
our world is complicated in this mirror
world it's things are a bit simpler
we're able to exclude pestilence it's
possible that we might be able to
extrude heuristics as well
and perhaps we can build on these
techniques to say something about pestle
and heuristic in our real world
um and the open questions uh so and very
interesting question from the
perspective of uniform worst case
um of uniform hardness randomness trade
offs is whether we can show
that average case harness of ph against
uniform adversaries implies a polynomial
stretched ph computer prg that's
something we don't know how to do i
mentioned this before
and is there kind of a nice way a
natural way of formulating ph minicrypt
and ruling that out and might that give
us some insight into um interminicrypt
in
our in our real world
that's all i have to say thanks
thanks so much for the talk so that's
the last part of this
session we have one we have time for one
more question so if you have questions
just ask him uh hello hello uh hi
are your reductions number books like in
the sense of switches previous works
oh uh no no they're uh they're pretty
black box actually i mean yeah so that's
that so yeah uh
we don't really have like any long black
box techniques going but it's
interesting to see whether the non-black
box techniques might be useful oh thank
you
well okay so i should add to that i mean
so for the in the uniform case in the
non-uniform case it's all kind of black
box in the uniform case um there's kind
of like uh when there's a result we get
with advice which is black box but then
removing the advice is not like so there
is a non-black box component but it's
not um as powerful as it is in sriji's
result somehow and it'd be nice to kind
of extend the power of that
yes thanks so much for
yeah so let's thank rahul again and uh
also thanks everybody for coming to the
discussion sorry for running late i
guess we also started it so yeah so the
next session will start at the 1pm so
so stay tuned if you want to go
yeah so that's all thanks so much
everyone for coming
you